asian culture here is just not as
visible in in the uk unfortunately you
know i think if i started making videos
where uncle roger is saying things like
oh i'm asian i love eating dog you know
then that would be a problem right but
to the people who
accuse me of uh
that character being a racist caricature
i would say i urge them to actually
listen to the things i'm saying
and see that
everything i say is lifting our people
up
[Music]
it's always hard to explain when people
ask what it's like going out in malaysia
i think it's it's a very normal
childhood i i got friends i got school
and
we did karaoke a lot you know it's like
it's like growing up in the uk we just
have different habits and different
things we do i realized when i first
wanted to do comedy when i was in
university in the u.s somewhere near
northwestern university just near
chicago
a few months afterwards i started doing
stand-up
just by myself and yeah i got hooked
since and i realized oh this is what i
want to do i would go go to work and
then do my data science job at the night
i'll go do an open mic or go go do a gig
somewhere travel to a gig come back
sleep go to work again the next day so i
was working a full-time job and still
working still performing four or five
nights a week it got to the point where
i was
performing so much that i
started taking more and more days off
from work and that you know people
aren't happy about that so i realized at
a certain point something has to give i
think for me it was a very
calculated risk it was more like i was i
i didn't just quit the job and then went
into comedy i was like okay i make this
amount i make a decent income through
comedy maybe i can make this work so it
was like it wasn't zero to 100 straight
away it was more like step by step let's
scale down the data science and scale up
the comedy
and i realized i want to i want to do
this comedy thing and really give this a
shot so that's when i quit i i went
full-time comedy in september 2019.
what did your parents make of it
my parents i think you know you know you
know how asian parents are usually they
they want their kids to have a stable
job because they came they didn't come
from much so they just want their kids
to have a stable job stable income
stable life that kind of thing so
my parents were very worried at first
and they were like you have a good job
as a data scientist why are you giving
this up they were worried but i kept
telling them i'm fine i'm doing okay
i'll try to make this work
they also didn't really understood what
stand-up was because they they were you
know grew up in malaysia their whole
lives and stand up is a pretty western
art form right so
at first they were like why are you why
are you doing this you know you're not
that funny you know they pick up you'll
come to my shows my dad told me they my
mom and dad they
they
they speak english but they don't really
get jokes because you need a certain
high level of command of the english
language to get things like sarcasm and
metaphors and how jokes work right so
when they i performed in malaysia one
time and they came to see me perform
they said they didn't really understood
what i said because you know when i'm
performing i speak like this it's a very
neutral neutral-ish english uh accent
and
i speak quite fast as well for an eight
from uh for asian standards so my dad
told me i didn't understand what you
were saying but i just laughed when
other people laughed you know i moved
too many for comedy and so i can drink
tap water and not die
it's [ __ ] awesome here right that
water
is skyping my parents right back in
malaysia i'm like hey don't try this at
home
just explain to me the sort of context
of when you came up with the the
character
doing character comedy was a goal of
mine i started researching how
uh asian middle older asian men act and
what they wear i sent the text to all my
friends asking them send me a picture of
your dad
and a bright colored polo was the by far
the most popular choice of outfit for
them uncle roger is a reflection of you
know the the middle-aged asian men the
middle-aged asian we call them uncles
back there that i grew up with they're a
bit sassy they know it all
but ultimately they're kind people and
they're very just stuck in their ways
you know so the first few things i made
were short little instagram clips
instagram tick tock clips 40 seconds
uh i remember the first one was um how
regular people answer the phone versus
how asian parents answer the phone
hey evelyn
hey i'm actually out right now can i
call you back when i get home all right
cool thanks
[Music]
hello hi how are you
when i first uploaded that to tiktok
instagram people liked it so i kept
making more of those short little things
oh here's how uncle roger makes rice
uh and i use a rice cooker and yeah it
went it hit hard you know getting i
think it got like a million views
overnight and to me that to me at the
time was really really big
and i thought to myself okay i think
people like this character let's see if
i can make something in a let's see i
can use this and make something longer
form
and that's when the first uh uncle roger
youtube video came about which was the
bbc food egg fried rice one
drain it drake
what's she doing
what you doing drain the oh my god
you're killing me woman hi i drink the
[ __ ] the voice she's draining rice with
colander it struck a chord with me
because
it was just the
the way she made rice was so bizarre
like egg fried rice in in asian culture
it's a very simple dish to make you know
it's it's all like whatever is left in
your fridge you just use it you know
like the leftover rice leftover
vegetables leftover meat whatever just
whack it in there this is just so
bizarre and so funny
and i yeah i just made a reaction video
i was like oh people like this so let's
let's let's make more and let's see
where this character can go
spoken on your podcast before
about people accusing you of
perpetuating
negative stereotype yeah sometimes i do
get feedback sometimes that uncle roger
perpetuates negative stereotypes for
asian people and
i see where they're coming from i'm
doing a character that is very close to
me and
it went so big because everybody can
relate to it you know people grew up in
asia they know an uncle roger in their
family
i view uncle roger as a celebration of
asian asianness and asian culture and
asian things in general
because you know uncle roger if you look
at the things i make uncle roger never
puts his own race down right he's always
he's very positive uh sometimes almost
too
uh positive for comedy but i'm
i'm when i make the character he's
always very positive about his own race
you know he's very proud of it and also
in western media
asian culture when i say asian here i
mean more east asian culture you know
chinese hong kong
that region taiwanese
asian culture here is just not as
visible in in the uk unfortunately i
think
you know if you look at tv programs here
i can't even think of one big asian
presenter or just one big asian guy you
can look up to
you know i think if i started making
videos where uncle roger is saying
things like oh i'm asian i love eating
dog you know then then there's a
then that that would be a problem right
but to the people who
accuse me of uh
that character being a racist caricature
i would say i urge them to actually
listen to the things i'm saying
and see that
everything i say is lifting our people
up i think the people who also think
ankara shouldn't have an accent
they're essentially saying that uncle
roger should sound white which is very
problematic in itself asians have
accents and sometimes we we want to do a
character with an accent and that
character
like uncle roger without an accent it
just wouldn't be right
you've now got over three million
subscribers on youtube and that's pretty
much happened just in the last year yeah
i know people who
have made videos for years and you know
not at my level of subscribers and i
don't take any of that for granted i
keep
i always want to challenge myself i keep
making videos that are better
uh the growth was insane when the first
uncle roger video came out with the bbc
food egg fried rice one it got written
up in all the newspapers in every single
asian country i was doing radio
interviews
i was doing zoom interviews with like
the philippines indonesia malaysia
singapore korea thailand everywhere
i appeared in variety uh yeah my social
medias just exploded overnight i
yeah i started started needing to build
a team around me because i was just
really stressed under all the workload
and offending of all the interview
requests and
uh just just everything everything
changed you know every it just blew up
and but uncle roger went viral on all
the platforms you know reddit twitter
take talk facebook youtube
uh and then
you guys picked it up lad bible picked
it up unilad or 9gag everywhere
so what does the future hold
uh the future
for me i want to keep making videos
because i'm still i still really enjoy
making them i enjoy the editing process
even though during the every edit
there's a point where i'm like oh this
video is going to be so sh
so bad but then after when the edit is
done you realize oh it's actually turned
out pretty good
i'm also hoping to do some more
ambitious things you know hopefully get
some sort of scripted production in the
works or have
have bigger scale projects you know
maybe a maybe a sitcom maybe a
non-scripted travel show that kind of
thing
who knows if that will happen or not but
regardless there are things that are
completely under my control and that's
just you know keep making videos that i
enjoy
and if you could say anything
i would say
hey keep doing what you're doing and
don't let the haters get to you uncle
now can you stop annoying me hi yeah
[Music]
like the other day i dm'd a rapper that
i want to get on the show and he
literally replied in five minutes and
was like yeah i'll do it i was just like
okay
this this cool this is good
who else are you keen to book
um
i'm keen to book drake
so
fingers crossed